こんにちは
スティーブ カウフマンです
今日はね 言葉の勉強においての
完璧主義について
話したいと思います
僕のビデオ好きであれば
是非登録してください
鐘のところで
クリックしてください
届けいきますので
お知らせが届きます
それとポッドキャストで
私の英語のビデオを
聞いているならば
それは英語の勉強のために
いいと思うんですけれども
是非コメントを残してください
それでね
その言葉の勉強というのは
あくまでそのコミュニケーションが
目的なんですよ
コミュニケーション
すなわち聞くこと分かる
読んだ場合は分かる
言いたいことは言える
それにですね
その完璧に理解する
完璧にその話 出来る 表現できる
それは目標としてあっても
いいんですけれども 必要はないです
えー言葉外国の言葉を
勉強するというのは
オリンピックのダイビングみたいな
ものじゃないんですよ
それを その いわゆる…何と言いますか
Performanceっていうかね えーまっ忘れました
パフォーマンスではないんですよ
点数がもう1番大切な
ことじゃないんですよね
その他の人の評価というか それよりも
いわゆるコミュニケーションが
できましたか
わかりましたか
言いたいこと言えましたかと
で当然あのー我々外国の言葉を
勉強する時にですね
ある程度その我々の脳がね
その新しい言葉に慣れてきます
だけどもその慣れる段階ではですね
もちろんその脳もね
それを少しずつパターンができるし
少しずつ少しずつこう…
我々のその新しい言葉に対する
コントロールが良くなるわけですけれども
そのパターンがその馴染みというのが
非常に個人的さがあるんですよ
自分の母国語
あるいは他のファクターが
非常に影響するわけですよ
だからみんなまちまちなんですよ
だからこの人は
この人より良いんだとか
この人の発音がいいとか
この人が文法的ミスが少ないとかね
それはそれほど大切じゃないんです
大切じゃないです
それで多少のアクセントがあってもですね
違和感ないんですよ
えーよく日本語の場合はですね
その外国人がね日本語を勉強する時に
最近はその日本語のその
ピッチアクセントというものに対する
非常にまあ重点を置いている
人もいるわけですけれども
えー私は日本に9年も
住んでてですね
日本語も30年ぐらい
ずっとお話してますけれども
そのピッチアクセントが
どんなことかも全然知らないんですよ
そういうことはもうあるっていうことも
10年前までは知らなかったんですね
日本に9年住んでても
それはそのじゃあ
ピッチアクセントは知らないから
自分の言いたいことを言えないかと
相手の言うことは分からないとかね
テレビ分からないとか
そういうことじゃないんですよ
だからもちろん私は
その他の外国語を勉強しなくて
日本語だけに集中すれば
その発音をもっと良くするために
そのピッチアクセントを
そういうそこに重点を置いてもいいんですけども
やらなくてもいいです
それは必要はないと思うんですよ
このYouTubeチャンネルでもね
スティーブが20カ国語
話せるというんだけども
この間イタリア語での会話はね
スティーブのイタリア語は
非常に悪かったという批判も受けますよね
ま当然それは言えると思うんですよ
完璧じゃないですよ
完璧じゃないイタリア語が
私のイタリア語よりも更に水準の低い
悪い言葉もあるわけですけれども
しかし一時的にはこの言葉に集中して
例えば韓国語あるいはチェコ語
集中してたくさんの語彙
その単語も勉強した訳ですよ
そしてその国に行って
その言葉でいろんな
コミュニケーションができたんですけど
今はできない すぐはできない
多分１日経ったらできると
思うけれどもすぐはできない
それじゃあこの言葉は知らないか？
というかそうじゃないんですよ
そうじゃないんです
だから それは僕の10本目とか15本目の
外国の言葉についても言えることですけれども
１つだけその外国語を勉強している
人にとって同じことなんですよ
完璧じゃないにしてもいい訳ですよ
続けて聞いたり
読んだり話しすればですね
少しずつ少しずつものになる
その完璧を追求する
精神がね逆にマイナスになる
だから人間がその恐れるわけ
ですよミスしたくないと
しかし実際には
コミュニケーションに重点をおけば
その文法とかその言葉遣いから
少しずつ少しずつ良くなるから
それよりも大切なのは
その言葉を使うと
たくさん聞いたり読んだり話しする
それで続ければ
少しずつ少しずつ進歩する
で ある人は早く進歩する
ある人は発音が良い
ある人はもう文法が正確である
様々なんですよ
それはどうでもいいです
その…そういう
その他の人との
比較ということじゃなくて
自分がその言葉の勉強は好きであるか
それ続くかどうか
その積極的な態度で続ければ
必ずさらに良くなる改善する
まそういうことで完璧というのは
言葉の勉強においてはですね
あまり良い目標では
ないと思います
じゃあ皆さん どうもさよなら